tengo el honor de saludarlos en nombre
de el pueblo ucraniano
y el pueblo que ama la libertad
y que por ocho años ha estado
resistiendo a la agresión rusa
a aquellos que han dado lo mejor de sí
han dado a sus hijos e hijas para
detener
este esta esta invasión a gran escala
por parte de rusia ahora
el futuro del país está decidiendo el
destino de nuestro pueblo se está
decidiendo seremos libres o si seremos
capaces de mantener nuestra democracia
rusia no solamente nos ha atacado a
nosotros ya nuestra tierra no solamente
a nuestras ciudades sino que es una
ofensiva brutal en contra de nuestros
valores de nuestros valores humanos
básicos
lanzaron tanques y aviones en contra de
nuestra libertad en contra de nuestro
derecho a vivir libres en nuestro país
escogiendo nuestro propio futuro
en contra de nuestros deseos de
felicidad nuestros sueños nacionales así
como los mismos sueños que ustedes
tienen ustedes estadounidenses
justo como cualquier persona en eeuu
recuerdo el memorial del rumor
las caras de sus presidentes aquellos
que pusieron las fundaciones de lo que
es hoy eeuu
con democracia independencia libertad y
con
cuidados para todos para aquellos que
trabajen duro y que viven de manera
honesta que respeten la ley nosotros en
ucrania queremos lo mismo para nuestro
pueblo
y todo eso es una parte normal
la vida
amigos estadounidenses
en su gran historia ustedes han tenido
patriotas que les han permitido
a comprendernos ahora
cuando los necesitamos cuando los
necesitamos en este momento recuerden a
pearl harbor recuerden esa
terrible mañana del 41 cuando los
atacaron con aviones solo recuérdenlo
recuerden el 11 de septiembre un día
terrible
del 2001 cuando la maldad trató de
tomarse sus ciudades
cuando las personas inocentes fueron
atacadas
atacadas desde el aire sí
justo como
se esperaba no pudieron detenerlo y
nuestro país está
sufriendo lo mismo todos los días en
este momento cada noche
durante ya tres semanas
como mariupol y nieve y vivo
rusia ha convertido el aire en una
fuente de muerte para miles de personas
las tropas son rusas
ya han lanzado más de 1.000 misiles
bombas han lanzados drones para matarnos
con precisión este es un terror que
europa no ha visto por 80 años y estamos
viviendo
la atención del mundo es demasiado pedir
crear una zona de exclusión aérea sobre
ucrania para salvar a las personas es
todo demasiado pedir pedir una zona de
discusión aérea algo que
rusia
algo para que rusia no pueda lanzar este
tipo de terror sobre nuestras ciudades y
esto es demasiado pedir ofrecemos una
alternativa
ya saben qué tipo de sistemas de defensa
necesitamos los s-300 y sistemas
similares saben todo lo que
dependemos para poder utilizar esto en
las zonas de combate para poder proteger
a nuestro pueblo a nuestra libertad a
nuestra tierra
aeronaves que también puedan ayudar a
los ucranianos
y saben
esto existe
pero están en tierra no están en los
cielos ucranianos defendiendo a nuestro
pueblo yo tengo un sueño
y esto puedo decirlo a todos ustedes yo
tengo una necesidad
necesito proteger nuestro cielo necesito
su decisión y su ayuda lo que significa
justamente eso lo mismo que ustedes
sienten cuando escuchan las palabras yo
tengo un sueño
estadounidenses amigos ucrania está
agradecida con eeuu por su abrumador
apoyo por todo lo que su gobierno y su
pueblo ha hecho por nosotros con armas y
con munición con entrenamiento con
finanzas con liderazgo desde el mundo
libre que nos ha ayudado a presionar
económicamente al agresor también
agradecido con el presidente bardem por
su compromiso sincero con la defensa de
ucrania y de nuestra democracia y la
democracia del mundo agradecido por la
resolución que reconoce a todos aquellos
que cometen cometen crímenes contra el
pueblo ucraniano como criminales de
guerra sin embargo ahora es cierto en el
momento más oscuro para nuestro país y
para toda europa que hago un llamado a
ustedes para que hagan más nuevos
paquetes de sanciones se necesitan de
manera constante cada semana hasta que
la maquinaria rusa de guerra se detenga
se necesitan restricciones para todos
aquellos
sobre las cuales se basa este régimen
ruso todos los políticos en la
federación rusa que se mantienen en sus
cargos y que
cortan lazos con aquellos que son
responsables con la agresión a ucrania
con los miembros de la duma con hasta el
último oficial que le falte moral para
acabar con el terror estatal todas las
compañías estadounidenses deben irse de
rusia a abandonar su mercado de manera
inmediata porque
ésta
manchado con nuestra sangre miembros del
congreso por favor tomen el liderazgo si
tienen
compañías en sus distritos para
financiarla
y maquinaria rusa deberían poner presión
yo les estoy pidiendo que se aseguren
que los rusos no reciban ni un solo
centavo que pueda ser utilizado para
destruir personas en ucrania
la destrucción de nuestro país la
destrucción de europa
todas las tiendas estadounidenses
deberían estar cerradas
a los bienes y productos rusos
tenemos que defender este principio en
todo el mundo ya nos convertimos en
parte de la coalición anti guerra la
coalición que une a muchos países
decenas de países aquellos que
reaccionaron en principio a la decisión
del presidente putin de invadir pero
tenemos que avanzar y hacer más tenemos
que crear nuevas herramientas para
responder de manera rápida y detener
invasión a gran escala de ucrania que
comenzó el 24 de febrero
sería justo sí
se determinarán en 24 horas y que esta
maldad fuera castigada de manera
inmediata hoy el mundo no tiene
tales herramientas
las guerras del pasado ha llevado a los
predecesores a crear instituciones que
deberían protegernos de la guerra pero
desafortunadamente no funcionan lo vemos
ustedes lo ven así que necesitamos
nuevas instituciones nuevas alianzas y
nosotros las ofrecemos estamos
proponiendo la creación de una
asociación
de países unidos por la paz
para detener los conflictos
inmediatamente y ofrecer todas las
y todo lo necesario ya sea armas ayuda
humanitaria apoyo político financiero
todo lo que se necesite para mantener la
paz rápido
ante la falta de detalles instituciones
debería dar asistencia a aquellos que
son víctimas de desastres naturales o
que enfrentan epidemias o crisis
humanitarias recuerdan lo difícil que
fue para el mundo hacerlo más simple
simplemente dar vacunas vacunas en
contra del joven para salvar vidas ante
nuevas variantes se pasaron meses
haciendo cosas como estas mucho más
rápido para asegurar que ninguna muerte
ocurriera en el mundo estadounidenses
amigos si tales alianzas existieran hoy
seríamos capaces de salvar miles de
vidas
en nuestro país
[Música]
aquellos que sufren de la destrucción
inhumana les pido que miren un vídeo
de lo que hicieron las tropas rusas en
nuestro país
tenemos que detenerlo
tenemos que evitar
esta destrucción y detener a los
agresores que quieren subyugar a otros